did you know that title seven of the
United States Code section 8313 a 1b
allows for a five-year sentence in the
federal slammer for selling llama poop
are you aware that title 21 part 139 of
the Code of Federal Regulations
prohibits the sale of improperly shaped
spaghetti noodles or that the swine
Health Protection Act forbids the
feeding of garbage to a pig unless said
garbage has been cooked by a garbage
cooker who holds a garbage cooking
permit you didn't know any of these
things but that's because you're not
Mike chase criminal defense attorney and
author of the new book how to become a
federal criminal an Illustrated handbook
for the aspiring offender perhaps the
world's foremost expert on vague and
dumb laws the man behind the crime add a
twitter handle has scoured through
countless criminal statutes and codes in
order to demonstrate the power of the
federal government at its most absurd i
sat down with chase to learn the roots
of his obsession with laws against
improperly shaped cheese whistling on a
CB radio and making unreasonable
gestures to a passing horse how to
become a federal criminal is sort of the
desk guide to all of the most arcane and
ridiculous federal crimes that you could
commit in the United States and there
are a combination of statutory
violations and regulatory violations but
things like selling graded cream cheese
or you know walking on the grass at the
Capitol things like that what are some
of the more ridiculous ones can give us
more some more examples because some of
them are really pretty hilarious a
personal favorite of mine is giving an
unreasonable gesture to a passing horse
on on in a national park and the law
doesn't define what an unreasonable
gesture is and and so you can kind of
get creative I think and I go through a
few of my ideas for fur obscene gestures
that you could make to a horse in the
book but the regulator's don't give you
sufficient guidance and in a lot of
cases all Congress does is basically say
hey look any violation of any regulation
that the Secretary of the Interior makes
you know that's a federal crime and so
oftentimes you have to go
to the Supreme Court to find out whether
you've committed a crime or not it is a
pretty hilarious book a lot of the even
illustrations and the examples are very
very funny
but I'm curious like there's a serious
undercurrent to this right I mean why
does this all matter is it is it just
shits and giggles or are there is there
some kind of underlying importance to
all of this there really is a serious
underpinning I mean people have been
giving different names to it we've
talked about executive overreach we've
talked about over-regulation over
criminalization there's a whole bunch of
names for it but the truth is that when
the country was founded there were
basically three federal crimes and a
government of limited powers so it was
treason counterfeiting and being a
pirate basically were the crimes and for
a long time after that
maybe the total crimes on the federal
books were about 20 but now some
scholars have estimated that that number
exceeds 300,000 and and here's really
what the problem is the problem is if
you can't know whether you're committing
a crime or not
is it really a crime and how much
respect for the more morally offensive
laws on the books
will there be if if you can never really
know if you're committing a crime
yeah and for each law that you mentioned
as nutty as it is you really do go into
how we got into this mess to begin with
right the funny thing is with all this
law right with all this regulation and
all this statute it's it's very hard for
a person to say what's in the books and
what's what's there and so people sort
of line up on different sides of the
debate they either say regulation is
inherently good or regulation is
inherently bad and the answer is it's
really a mix sometimes a law is really
truly trying to protect people from some
harm out there but maybe it goes too far
maybe it misses the mark maybe it's been
applied unconstitutionally and so it was
important to delve into the reasons for
these laws because some are
well-intentioned but but they may be
over broad too vague or outdated and as
ridiculous as they are nobody sets out
to like make a preposterous law and put
it on the books what is the source of a
lot of these there are certain
categories that seem to provoke bizarre
laws we all know that the Constitution
gives Congress certain powers right they
can regulate commerce they can regulate
the high seas you know they can
certain territories right commerce being
probably the most broad statutory
authority but they basically give blank
checks to agencies and say hey look any
violation of any regulation on a
particular topic that you write
that's criminally enforceable and so
where the action is I'll say is food you
know public land on high seas and money
for example obviously is it is another
place and and why my personal favorites
is in the mail right because everything
that passes through the mail is
potentially a federal crime and
poop-poop is on the top of my list of
things poop and animal semen are about
the the best kind of crimes that you can
commit because there's a shockingly high
number of poop and semen crimes on the
books Congress does seem to have uh some
sort of scatological fixation with llama
poop right the shoveling llama poop in
wrong places could be a federal offense
any llama that comes to this country has
a mandatory quarantine period when they
get here it's like thirty days or
something like that and you cannot go
visit your llama without permission and
that can be a heartbreaking time in any
llama owners life obviously but if you
want to bring home some poop mm-hmm you
know just to remind you of your llama
that is a quarantine violation are these
special interests drawing these laws
where what is the sort of genesis of a
lot I will admit there's not a llama
poop special interest right but yeah the
genesis of a lot of regulations are
special interest so here's a great
example right one of the earliest kind
of federal crimes that came about that
was a violation of these regulations
made by executive branch agencies was in
margarine and anybody can guess where
the margarine regulation came from it
was big butter right and so the dairy
industry came in and they said we don't
like this new kid on the block it's
every bit as tasty as our product and
people seem to not know the difference
in mind and it's cheaper and so the
dairy lobby went to Washington and said
we need comprehensive butter control and
they got it they got a butter bill
passed it actually was a law called an
act defining butter and and it required
all kinds of crazy things and some of it
remains on the books
today interesting is like the bacon law
right there the packaging for bacon I
found that really interesting it
explained a longtime fascination as to
why every package of bacon you can
actually see the bacon in it yeah the
bacon window bacon window yeah I call it
the window of truth because I think that
it really is the purpose that it serves
and yeah of course it's it's to tell the
consumer hey this is how fatty the bacon
you are getting and it has to be a
representative slice right they can't
just put the good stuff on top and so
you know that's why that window appears
yeah it's shocking to me that there's
not a window on potato chip bag so that
you can see that there's only six potato
chips in the bag but so far we've got
the bacon rule we've heard a lot of
criticism in the Trump administration
about this thing called the
administrative state right this idea
that it's not lawmakers making the laws
that our elected representatives with a
sense of discussion and debate and due
process but they're outsourcing things
to agencies and federal bureaucracies
that are actually making the real
details of the laws and that's
ultimately what really matters is that
an implicit critique that you're making
in the pinnace book yeah I mean look
article 1 section 1 of the United States
Constitution says that Congress has the
lawmaking power period full stop it's
not theirs to give away and that's
something called the non delegation
doctrine which is sort of been dormant
or dead for a number of decades but the
truth is it is Congress's job to make
the law there's a lawmaking branch
that's why we call them lawmakers but
they have given away they've ceded that
authority to executive branch agencies
so now you have the enforcers also doing
the regulating the lawmaking so they're
both picking what is a violation of the
law and then prosecuting those
violations of the law and to be fair
like not all the laws in your book are
bad necessarily like the law threat
against threatening clowns that's a good
law for I'm pro clown I'm definitely pro
clown almost anything can be considered
a drug paraphernalia that's that some of
those laws are like just overly vague in
that way anything can be drug
paraphernalia if anybody who had a
creative roommate in college knows that
anything can be drug paraphernalia but
there's a couple of categories that that
Congress has specifically articulated
like miniature spoons that are less than
1/10 of a cubic centimeter in level
capacity
and that actually derives from some
interesting congressional testimony
about the McDonald's mix spoon which was
used to stir coffee no I'm very glad
they're spending a lot of time on this
kind of stuff and it's not just Congress
right like you mentioned the Powell
decision right the Supreme Court spends
a shocking amount of time discussing
these sort of absurd laws why are they
doing that is there underneath these
absurd laws are there like crucial
constitutional questions at play sure
there often are I mean one of the main
constitutional questions that occurs not
just the federal level but at the state
level as well is this question of void
for vagueness right unconstitutional
vagueness and and so yeah in the Powell
decision the statute basically said any
concealable firearm and so that's a
crime to mail you can't mail a
concealable firearm so you and I think
well that's clearly a pistol or some
small gun that I can put on my body but
in the Powell decision the court was
looking at a 22 and a half inch
sawed-off shotgun that was sent through
the mail and they said well look if you
dress appropriately you could probably
conceal that and so I don't know what
the limits are there's some big people
out there they could hide a lot of stuff
and so it's those kind of vague terms
that often peak the courts interest tell
us a little bit about yourself what does
your are you an expert and why are you
an expert in these absurd laws why
should we take your opinion seriously
about this crazy stuff I don't know if
anybody should take my opinion seriously
about this but I will tell you that I'm
fun at parties because I spend all my
time reading the Code of Federal
Regulations in the US Code and so that
what really it is is it's just I've
committed to the grunt work of going
through all of these pages and reading
all these sections and subsections and
subparagraphs so you know by day I'm a
white-collar criminal defense lawyer
that's what they say but I mean I'll
defend anybody for anything but but the
truth is that I by night have been
spending a lot of time trying to count
the number of crimes because the
Department of Justice said that they
couldn't do it they tried in the 80s and
quit and so I said look if I do one a
day I only need like 800 years to finish
the job and and then I'll be able to say
that I counted them all so that's what
I've been doing
that's what Twitter is for ultimately
Twitter's for that and destroying other
people absolutely destroy which
continues to be illegal right at least
for the time being right and you do
mention in the beginning of the book
like this is a like it's almost like a
legalistic disclaimer like this book is
a book of humor and not serious legal
advice is there some why I like I
couldn't figure out why even put that in
there that is there some law insisting
that you are somewhat something to sue
you if they thought oh this is legal
advice I should commit all these eight
hundred crimes the truth is if somebody
comes to me and says is it illegal to X
right whatever the the blank is filled
with the answers I don't know I can't I
can't sign a piece of paper that says
hey it's totally legal to do any
particular thing because you can't read
all the laws I haven't gotten through
all of them yeah even though I've been
doing it for five years and so I think
what's important is for people who read
the book to know it's a work of humor
don't do anything in the book yeah
you're probably not going to get charged
for selling you know runny ketchup but
you could and right we'll talk about
that later but but yeah it's it's
important that people know that the
truth is that the specter of criminal
liability hangs over all of us all the
time and that's why people find
themselves before the courts and even
the Supreme Court our people often even
charged with these crimes or is it
extremely rare so it depends which
crimes you're talking about I mean you
know we expect prosecutors to exercise
something called prosecutorial
discretion what that ends up meaning is
that they charge mostly gun crimes drug
crimes immigration crimes and fraud
crimes that's overwhelming majority of
it now say the estimates are one and a
half to two percent of the federal
docket is filled with these
administrative crimes right violations
of regulations that's still thousands of
people each year that's thousands of
lives people who have to get a lawyer go
to court potentially appeal after a
conviction maybe try to go to the
Supreme Court to find out if it's
unconstitutional and so yeah people are
charged with them and I go through a
couple of examples in the book of people
who were charged with things that they
never thought would be a federal crime
maybe maybe a violation or a small state
misdemeanor or something of that effect
but not something that would get them a
federal criminal record is it like if a
federal prosecutor wants to throw the
book at you
they will add these charges on if
federal prosecutor wants to throw the
book at you it's my book that they throw
but yes really there's a coercive
element to it right so if we look at
these right now that all the discussion
is about processed crimes right people
talk about obstruction of justice they
talk about lying to federal agents the
truth is if they can't get you on a
substantive crime that everybody agrees
is morally reprehensible they can often
get you on lying to the feds because
they decide what's a lie they decide
whether they think that you were being
truthful or not and it's incumbent upon
you to defend yourself in in federal
court and and so yeah if you go into a
meeting with federal prosecutors nobody
can tell you that you're not admitting
to a federal crime when you describe
something that you did because you may
not know whether there's a federal
regulation or a statute that covers that
conduct and that's a problem and you can
actually learn a lot about the legal and
judicial philosophies of different
administration's based on this stuff
like for example the Obama
administration was quite fond of the
MBTA the migratory bird acts right my
heartburn treatment treaty I Frank you
and then the Trump administration looked
at that same law and said no we that's
vague and ridiculous and we should
strike that down is that is this a
window on two different administrations
MBTA situation is one example where yes
the Obama administration said accidental
bird deaths so if you get a in a really
clean plate glass window and an Egret
flies into your window and breaks its
neck can you technically be charged yes
Obama administration said but we're
gonna trust prosecutors not to charge
those more ridiculous cases and
including you know during the Obama
administration a utility was charged for
a bunch of birds dying in windmills
accidentally nobody tried to kill those
birds
but then the Trump administration looked
at it and said well wait a second this
is the epitome of vague law if well if
we've just seeded what's a crime and
what's not a crime to the executive
branch that's sort of over broad and
impermissible so we're issuing new
guidance saying that those kind of
accidental bird deaths are not crimes
now nothing in the law changed nothing
Congress passed changed you could go
look at the text and see the same words
but two different administrations have
said
is a crime and one's not a crime without
a change in the law but what I will tell
you is the same Trump administration has
used the regulatory power to create and
change crimes on the books as well we
saw the bump stock ban in in March and
basically with the stroke of a pen
essentially doing the exact same thing
that the Obama administration was
criticized for the Trump administration
made a whole new class of previously
legal products into criminal contraband
and without going through the
legislative process so every
administration is guilty of it in some
respect it's maybe a question of degree
it was the Department of Justice the
that issued regulation they changed the
regulation that interpreted what a
machine gun is so essentially by
changing the definition of a machine gun
they created a whole new class of crime
so on day one you could illegally
possessed it on day two you were a
federal criminal
why did you dedicate this book to the US
Congress like any you know great
comedian I have ghost writers and
Congress is my ghostwriter I couldn't
have done any of the book without them
and and it's because really what they've
done is again I don't think anybody's
intentionally created the more
ridiculous crimes a lot of them have
been created by accident right the
Congress writes a law that says any
violation that's a crime and then the
regulator's go about their business
making regulations and then somebody
sits down like me and they start
tweeting about it and they go
technically you know you made it a crime
to you know submit a stamp in the
migratory bird stamp contest and you use
computer-generated art you're not
allowed to use that you have to paint a
duck or something like that but but the
truth is they're not looking to create
crimes all the time but they do and they
should be Congress should be more
careful about giving away that criminal
enforcement power what can be done about
this is there is a law another law that
needs to be passed what how can we slow
this sort of thing down Congress can go
through and look at the statutes that I
cite in the book that give away this
blanket criminal enforcement power to
the agencies and then it can maybe take
a look at those statutes because
remember the reason that there's 300,000
federal crimes is not because of
criminal statutes right there's maybe a
couple thousand federal criminal
statutes
but if they go through those few that
give away this blanket authority to
regulators to make crimes and change
that so that it's required that if
something's gonna be criminally punished
it must specifically say so in the act
that would eliminate a huge number of
these federal crimes right in order for
a regulator to make it a crime it has to
specifically say so and Congress needs
to approve it that would be a good step
in the right direction Congress can also
look at bad regulations and use this
little used act called the Congressional
review act and they can go through and
look at the regulations and say we
disagree and we're overriding this
regulatory action but they don't like to
do that because it's not politically
popular to do it and you did all the
illustrations in this book and the
illustrations are really wonderful they
you have really captured that kind of
soul-sucking bureaucratic diagram that
tells people that tells people what to
do and how to do it right yeah is that
the look you were going for yeah exactly
I mean and in fact if you walk through
the Code of Federal Regulations you'll
even see some similar type illustrations
it's just this government you know no
joy expressionless sometimes faceless
figure doing some prohibited act and no
color either that's very important yeah
that's very important yeah color color
might might suggest hope or some sort of
positivity and I wanted to crush that
stamp that out of the beaver yeah that
made me feel good yeah my chase thank
you very much the book is how to be a
federal criminal and it's out in
bookstores June for very good I'm Todd
crane for a reason